[music playing]
NARRATOR: In 1799,
Napoleon Bonaparte
seized power in
France by plotting
a coup within another coup.
And he did it all without
shedding a drop of blood.
One year before the coup, France
was at war with Great Britain
and Russia, Austria,
the Ottoman Empire, and
some German and Italian states.
But Napoleon was
focused on Great Britain
and wanted to cut
off the country's
roots to its profitable
trading outposts in India.
Even though much of his fleet
was captured or destroyed
by the British at the
Battle of the Nile,
Napoleon still managed
to capture and hold Egypt
to cut off British trade
routes and even attack targets
deeper into the Ottoman Empire.
But back home, the French
weren't faring as well,
suffering a series of defeats
against their European enemies
across the first half of 1799.
The French people became fed
up with their current system
of government known
as the Directory,
the fourth different
system of government
since the beginning of
the French Revolution
10 years earlier.
The Directory system included
two legislative bodies,
a council of 500, a chamber of
elected men that proposed laws,
and the Council of Ancients,
250 elected men over 40
years old that approved laws.
The two bodies
also work together
to choose the
directors themselves,
five executives of equal power
responsible for enforcing laws.
But by 1799, the Directory
had brought France into war
and near economic ruin.
The people largely looked
to the country's military
for leadership.
This is where Napoleon
saw his chance.
When British ships temporarily
retreated from France's ports,
Napoleon left Egypt and
returned home a hero.
Meanwhile, another
prominent Frenchman
had been plotting to seize power
from the weakened Directory.
Emmanuel Joseph Sieyes, better
known by his religious title,
the Abb Sieyes, was elected
as a director in May of 1799.
He had long been one of the most
influential political figures
for his writings that partly
inspired the French Revolution.
But Sieyes hated the Directory,
finding the executive
too weak to effectively govern.
So soon after Napoleon's
return to Paris,
the two men met in secret.
They agreed to a coup that would
allow Sieyes to place himself
at the head of a new
government formed with the help
of Napoleon and his loyal army.
There were other conspirators,
including Minister of Foreign
Affairs Talleyrand
and Lucien Bonaparte,
President of the Council of 500
and Napoleon's younger brother.
On the morning of 18
Brumarie, or November 9,
the plan was set into motion.
Sieyes and Lucien
Bonaparte informed
their respective legislative
bodies there was a plot
to overthrow the government.
But they lied and said it was
being led by the Jacobins,
the party that had carried
out France's reign of terror
five years earlier.
The lawmakers were
moved for their safety
to a palace in St. Cloud,
a suburb of France.
Conveniently, Napoleon
himself was placed
in charge of their protection.
Meanwhile, three of
the five directors
had resigned in coordination
with the coup, Sieyes, his ally
Roger Ducos, and Paul
Barras, a former lover
of Napoleon's wife Josephine.
Talleyrand had been
given 2 million
francs to bribe
Barras to resign,
but he resigned on his own.
So Talleyrand just pocketed
the money for himself.
The next day, the
Council of Ancients
were receptive to
Napoleon's argument
that the government
needed to be reorganized.
But the Council of 500
needed more convincing.
So Napoleon marched into
their chamber with grenadiers
by his side.
The legislators erupted
in anger, some charging
at Napoleon with daggers.
Amidst the chaos,
Lucien Bonaparte
used the attacks on his
brother as an excuse
to dissolve the Council of 500.
Napoleon's troops dispersed
the rest of the council.
The Council of Ancients then
dissolved the Constitution,
replacing the Directory
with three consuls, Sieyes,
Roger Ducos, and Napoleon.
Sieyes' coup was complete.
But Napoleon was not
interested in sharing power.
The new government quickly
drew up the Constitution
of the Year VIII,
and Napoleon made
sure he was its chief editor.
With the new constitution,
Napoleon wrested
control away from Sieyes,
using his supreme popularity
to declare himself first consul
with Sieyes and Ducos secondary
in power.
Napoleon had succeeded in
his coup within a coup,
setting himself up to
ultimately become dictator,
and all without a
single life lost.